on the economy in march you said
that nobody should be penalized for
doing the right thing
does that remain true today would you
repeat that promise to the british
people absolutely look at what
the chancellor is saying today we're
continuing to do everything we can to
support
uh the workforce support jobs
livelihoods uh throughout the crisis
and again some very creative and
imaginative uh
proposals from the chancellor but here
what were
the really important thing is that
everybody follows the
the guidance that we've that we've set
out and that's why
i'm here today in north america talking
to the police
about uh what they're doing to to
underpin
to to support the enforcement of uh
those rules and it's
absolutely vital that everybody does it
i know that people sort of think well
it's a great package of
of new rules to uh depress the virus
but will it be enforced and my message
is
yes it will be and there will be serious
fines for people
who don't comply but how does the
promise
that nobody will be penalized for doing
the right thing square with the fact
that today
your chancellor is announcing that he is
pulling life support
from a large number of jobs which aren't
viable because of coronavirus
you're on course for large numbers of
job losses what do you say to the people
who are about to lose their jobs
where are they going to get new ones
well the chancellor is being totally
realistic with
people about the prospects of the of the
economy things will be
will be tough what we're saying to
people who who do the right thing is
as you put it sam who who self-isolate
uh when they
are contacted by nhs tests and traits
they will get support
as you know there's a there's 500 pounds
to support them
but there's also a 10 000 pound fine
potentially
if you if you don't comply and that's
it's absolutely vital
that we all work together now to get the
r down
uh get the virus back under control and
then
and simultaneously allow education and
the economy
to continue that is the best thing for
jobs
for growth in this country today is one
of the biggest days for your government
it's the day that your chancellor is
starting to have to give out
the bad news why aren't you with him
sitting next to him on the green benches
taking responsibility for some of the
most important decisions that your
government is ever going to have to take
well i of course i fully support the
the package of measures that we've
jointly uh drawn up what i'm doing here
today
is is setting out the vital the vital
corollary of of those measures
they they won't help unless everybody
works together we all work together
to drive the virus down and the way we
can do that
is follow the guidance the the rule of
six uh hands face space
make sure that you you self-isolate if
you're contacted by nh
test and and trace uh 500 pounds if you
do
uh 10 000 pound fine if you don't uh 200
pound fine for not wearing a mask in the
in the right place
uh i think a ten thousand pound fine
potentially if you
organize a group of a gathering of more
than thirty you know these are these are
very
very considerable fines and it is
important
that everybody works together to as i
say
drive the virus down now stitch in time
saves nine and protect the economy funny
you've launched today
the nhs coronavirus app in england and
wales
but why should anybody follow its
instructions to self-isolate
when studies and your own officials
admit that it produces one in three
false positives and matt hancock
this morning was saying it's not
compulsory the crucial thing is for
people to
follow the guidance and when you're
contacted by nature nhs testing trace
and told that
you've been in the presence of somebody
with chronovirus
we're going to give you support payment
to help you through the period of
self-isolation
and you should do that because that's
the best way to stop the spread of the
virus
and and just bear in mind now that there
are also
uh fines uh for people who who don't uh
follow
the guidance and that is what i'm trying
to say today our police do an amazing
job
i don't want to add extra burdens to
them at all where
as you know we're increasing the number
of police officers on the
streets of this country by 20 000 a lot
of them being recruited
here in northamptonshire where they're
doing an outstanding job they have all
sorts of things to do but what they must
also do now
is help us to enforce the
guidance help the public to work
together
get it get the virus to get the rate of
reproduction of the virus down
protect education and the economy and
save lives
the app prime minister you didn't answer
about that
it is true to say that you don't have to
follow the
record that's absolutely right and what
i'm saying to people
is look at the people who are contacted
by
nhs test and trace who are told if
you're told
that you've come into contact with
somebody an index case of
of coronavirus then you should take the
action uh that
uh that they tell you to do 500 pounds
support
per week to help you in that period and
of course
uh i'm afraid uh i don't and nobody
wants to put these fines in place you
know this is the last thing
uh any of us want to to see in this
country which is a you know a great
freedom-loving country but we've got to
work together now
uh to suppress the virus allow education
and and the economy to continue that's
the
that's the the balance in this package
it's about
working together to drive down the virus
now
but also uh keeping education and the
economy
going and that's what the chancellor is
also setting out today